بس عايز اقول ده ده ما نقدرش نعزله يعني
عن انه كان في في المجتمع المصري كان فيه
توجه عند البعض حتى جمال عبد الناصر وخالد
محي الدين قالوا ان هم راحوا للاخوان يعني
ولكن قالوا ما قالوش ان احنا كنا اخوانيين
لكن راحوا عايز اقول دي كانت ليست تهمه
بقدر ما انه كان تيار موجود
لكن مؤكد انه الافكار افكار الشعراوي فيها
واخده من هذا الملح حتى فكره علاقته بالفن
خدها من حسن البنا من حسن البنا اه اللي
حسن البنا كان يقول ايه حلاله حلال وحرامه
حرام حصل البنا استثمر في الفن وجهه نظرك
قبل انور وجدي بالصدفه حكى الواقعه يعني
كنت بتمنى المشوار طبعا
يعني ايوه في ست سنه سته واربعين قبله فهو
يعني قال قابلته وقال له ازيك يا اكسلانس
كلمه اكسلانس كانت في الثقافه المصريه انت
عارف بتستخدم يعني ما تعنيش اي حاجه غير
انك انت بتعلن من المخاطب لكن هو ما كانش
يعني مش قادر يقول له مولانا الشيخ
ما بصليش
بانتظام انت فاكرين ان احنا مثلا احنا على
طول ان احنا بنعمل مبيقات احنا كويسين قال
له لا بالعكس اعمل فن كويس
وحلا له حلال وحرام وحلال حرام وعمل مسرح
كمان مين عنده كان عنده مسرح الاخوان
المسلمين
من الفنانين راحت عندهم اشتغلت وكانت
المراه بتطلع كمان في مسرح الاخوه في
المسرح الاخوان يعني عايز اقول كان عندهم
توجه بالفن يملكه البلد وانا متذكر في
السنه اللي حكمنا فيها الاخوان
الحكم مصر يعني
ايام مرسي 2012 لما بداوا انا كنت بروح
الاوبرا المصريه فكنت بقابل اخوانيه
فهم كان في ذهنهم يعني انت اول حاجه تفكر
فيها ايه الاخوان ضد الاوبرا الاوبرا بقى
بيلبسه ومحزق وبتاع فقال لي لا احنا هنعمل
اوبرا شرعيه يعني يعني
نستكشف الابره هذه حتى الاوبرا عايزين
ياخدوها ان هم بس باسلوبهم اللي هي اللي
هو يقتل الابره يعني عملتها شرعيه من وجهه
نظره مش هيبقى طبعا الحقيقه كان التركيبه
هو خد من دي بقى حلال
يقال حتى انه انور وجدي معلش عارف انه بس
عايز اقفل الجمله انه انور وجدي في ليلى
بنت الفقراء عمل غنوه في المولد مول
السيده زينب انت عارف في مصر اموال دي
يعني من الثقافه
فغنت ليلى مراد وكانت مسيحيه اسف كانت
يهوديه كانت لسه لم تسلم غنت لبنت بنت
النبي السيده زينب في غنوه يعني